there's one map you have to see to
understand this conflict between Hamas
and Israel Gaza is the small strip of
land that has 2 million Palestinians
living in it after a short war in the
60s Israel captured a bunch of land the
map went from looking like this to this
Israel eventually gave Cai back to Egypt
but they continued to occupy this small
strip of land called Gaza in 2005 Israel
withdrew from Gaza and turned it over to
the authority of the Palestinians it was
quickly taken over by this anti-israel
group called Hamas which gets us back to
this map as soon as Hamas took over
Israel and to a lesser extent Egypt
started controlling everything that went
in and out of the strip so since Hamas
has launched these rocket Land and Sea
attacks Israel has used this blockade to
cut off the 2 million Palestinians
living here from fuel food and supplies
their power plant has run out of gas and
it is a horrible humanitarian situation
all of this is yet another chapter in
this decades long pattern of Israeli
occupation and Palestinian resistance
much of it peaceful but some of it like
this horrifically violent